you started acting young relatively
young um I did my first film when I was
17 an Australian film called Spotswood
and then I did some more theater and I
went to drama school for a little while
dropped out of there and then Muriel's
Wedding came along that was my second
this was my second film I was a baby I
was 20 when I made this and it was
hugely life-changing and there is no way
in the world at that age that I ever
would have imagined sitting here now 25
26 years later it is a huge honour and
incredibly overwhelming in the best
possible way so this is gonna be kind of
broad but thinking back to your
seventeen year old self what was it
about acting why acting you know what
what drew you to it well then I think
about when I was 14 desperate to be in
the School Musical we were doing and it
really woke me up I suddenly felt like I
could really express myself and I think
I became addicted to simply doing that
accessing parts of myself that I never
really could and finding an outlet for
them very selfish so wait a minute so
the appendix thing was that before or
after 14 I was 11 all right tell them I
lied I pretended I had appendicitis in
it they were taken out she took it to
the point of surgery so you were acting
before 14
my dad says like I came out of the womb
just saw the light and had jazz hands I
did a lot of dancing before I discovered
acting yes
so when Muriel came your way where were
you in life you were an actress you've
done a movie already right yeah I've
done that one film Spotswood I think I
was delivering pizzas I had I'd Benton
Ida which then is the National Institute
of Dramatic Art in Sydney and whilst
they're in my second year I was offered
to leave and work at the Sydney Theatre
Company with a brilliant theoretical
Neela
you're playing Sonya in uncle vanya
opposite geoffrey rush and I couldn't
say no it was a big leap because they
make you feel like drama school is
everything but I remember talking to my
then agent and she it was a year away
from me riyals wedding and I said I
don't wanna leave do the play and then
not have anything else to do and she
said well there is this one thing
waiting to be financed you know gave me
a basic description of it weirdly a year
later I was just thinking I wonder what
happened to that call Tara she was like
this is crazy timing because it is
happening she was gonna call me about it
so that was you mentioned the people
you're working with in the theater that
was part of what ended up being kind of
a big Australian Invasion of actors
hitting sort of a more global stage were
you conscious of that I know you all
were just do the baby had no idea what I
was doing it was all one foot in front
of the other this was the first big
movie rachel Griffiths had as well right
yes yes yeah I think she does some TV in
Australia before this I think for
everybody involved it was it was the big
life-changing
yeah and gave us careers I mean we
didn't know what it was at the time but
now in retrospect we know that